movies are a great way to let us escape
from reality but sometimes the stories
they tell Don't Stray very far from it
we'll be looking at some epic tales
about Underdog heavyweight boxers some
terrifying Tales from Southeast Asia
that inspired a classic horror franchise
and the hard fact behind the well-loved
fiction Star Wars Rocky is one of the
most iconic boxing movies of all time
starring Sylvester Stallone as the
underdog boxer Rocky Balboa the movie
tells the story of Rocky's rise from a
small time fighter to a contender for
the heavyweight championship what many
people don't know is that the character
was actually inspired by a real-life
boxer named Chuck wepner wepner like
Rocky was a journeyman boxer who got a
shot at the heavyweight title and went
the distance against Muhammad Ali in
1975. Stallone was so inspired by
wepner's story that he wrote the script
for Rocky in just three days Nacho Libre
is a comedy starring Jack Black as
Ignacio a cook who wants to become a
Luchador the movie's based on the real
life story of Ray tormenta a Mexican
Catholic priest who became a mask
wrestler to support his orphanage Frey
whose real name is Sergio began
wrestling in the 1960s and continued to
do so for over 20 years he never
revealed his true identity until the
late 1990s when he was forced to retire
due to health issues A Nightmare on Elm
Street is a classic horror movie that
introduced us to the iconic villain
Freddy Krueger the movie tells the story
of a group of teenagers who are
terrorized by him in their dreams while
the character of Freddy Krueger is
fictional the movie was inspired by a
series of real-life tragedies in
Southeast Asia in the late 1970s dozens
of refugees from Cambodia Lao and
Vietnam passed away in their sleep due
to conditions known as sudden unexpected
nocturnal end syndrome the cause of the
syndrome is still unknown but it
inspired writer and director Wes Craven
to create the character of Freddy
Krueger the Indiana Jones movies are
some of the most beloved
action-adventure films of all time
starring Harrison Ford as the daring
archaeologist Indiana Jones the movie
follows Jones as he travels the world
battling not sees searching for ancient
artifacts and getting into all sorts of
things while the character of Indiana
Jones is fictional the movies were
inspired by the real life adventures of
archaeologist Hiram Bingham Bingham was
the first person to explore the ruins of
Machu Picchu in Peru and his discoveries
captivated the world his Expeditions and
Adventures in the early 20th century
helped to fuel the popular imagination
about archeology and Adventure so Star
Wars is one of the most beloved movie
branches of all time with a devoted fan
base that spans Generations now the
movie takes place in a galaxy far far
away and follows the adventures of Jedi
Knights Smugglers and Rebels as they
battle against the evil empire while the
story and characters of Star Wars are
fictional the movies were inspired by a
variety of real-life sources including
mythology classic literature and even
World War II Creator George Lucas has
cited The Works of Joseph Campbell and
the concept of the hero's journey as
major influences on the movies 300 is a
visually stunning movie about the Battle
of Thermopylae in which 300 Spartan
soldiers fought against a massive
Persian army the movie has some epic
battle scenes that I still can't fathom
actually happening to real people it's
also based on the graphic novel by Frank
Miller but the story is also rooted in
history the Battle of Thermopylae took
place in 480 BC during the Persian Wars
and the brave stand of the Spartans
against overwhelming odds has become
legendary while the movie takes some
liberties with the historical facts it
still captures the Epic scale and
heroism of the battle Anastasia is an
animated movie that tells the story of
Anastasia Romanov the youngest daughter
of the last tsar of Russia the movie
follows Anastasia as she tries to
uncover her past and reclaim her
identity after her family is killed by
the Bolsheviks during the Russian
Revolution while the movie takes son
liberties with the historical facts it
is based on the real life story of
Anastasia Romanov yeah Anastasia and her
family were executed in 1918 but rumors
persisted for decades that she'd
survived in the 1990s the discovery of
romanov's remains confirmed that
Anastasia and her family definitely
didn't survive not to bring down the
vibe or anything and speaking of Vibes
this one is definitely a tearjerker the
blind side's a heartwarming movie about
a wealthy Southern family who takes in
an unhoused teenager named Michael Orr
and helps him become a star football
player the movie is based on the true
story of Michael Oher who went to play
for the Baltimore Ravens in the NFL or
grew up in poverty and had a difficult
childhood but he was taken in by the Tui
family and given the support he needed
to succeed the movie highlights the
power of kindness compassion and the
impact that a caring family can have on
someone's life movies can be a powerful
way to tell stories and Inspire us from
the Underdog Story of Rocky to the epic
battles of 300 and Star Wars these
movies remind us that truth can be just
as exciting and inspiring as fiction
even when movies take some liberties
with the facts they can still capture
the essence of the real life stories and
the people that inspired them